The joe rogan experience.
We're just trying to get our money look at before and after.
That's crazy.
As Christ 2009 to 2016 whoa.
That's amazing.
Testosterone is real people.
That's more testosterone.
That's that.
That's the job,
but not having,
it's real too,
for sure.
Yeah.
Tough mentally to,
yeah.
There's not much you can do either.
The other thing about it is like once your body doesn't produce anymore and
you're in your late thirties like that and you've been juicing for a long time,
there's like Clomid and stuff that tries to,
or eight to eight CT or HTC.
What is true?
Is that a mood that's a cell phone either way,
hcg or something,
whatever it is,
but it's supposed to boost your testosterone naturally,
but never to the levels when you're injecting that John,
but juice,
no.
Not only that though.
You can't take that stuff off UFC.
Right.
It's illegal.
I'm just saying.
Well,
yeah,
that's true.
When I guess when he retires,
he can do whatever the fuck he wants.
Yeah.
When he retires or goes to rise in Kim.
Imagine Ufc let him out of the contract and then all of a sudden he disappears
for like eight months and just we're here just locked in the house with horse
meat back,
just just filet of horse all day.
He's eating that Canelo meat and goes back to dead lift and hanging out with
power lifters.
Steps out of the fucking house in Holland six months later take tied around two
97 yes.
Yeah.
I want that journey for him.
I want that because I went on board of that train is only one way can happen
dude.
How about Kelly and hot for fucking Clenbuterol and they're saying it's in the
meat in Mexico.
It is a small trace amounts and everyone's like,
oh,
the fights off.
Trust me,
it's boxing.
That flight is not off.
There's way too much money involved.
That is a real fact though,
is that one particular substance he tested positive for exists in meat
Clenbuterol.
Yeah,
and also it's not like a straight steroid.
It's a,
it's,
you know,
guys use it to cut weight and stuff like that and it's such a small trace
amount.
They're going to be fine.
Yeah.
That's such a great fight.
Triple g canola man.
It's a very good fight and it's way better than the first one.
Cinco de Maya.
Why do you think it's going to be better?
I,
cause I,
I think triple g didn't fight like himself.
He wasn't,
he has that mix in style.
He's a little reserved and then you know,
Canelo was moving too much.
I think now that they're going to be,
we're getting like the real fight now.
I don't,
I don't think the judges fuck this one up.
You never know though.
It's shady.
I loved the first fight.
I loved it.
I thought let me to triple g one it going away though.
I really thought he won.
Me Too.
I think a lot of people did.
A lot of people thought that was a poor draw.
That's why I think,
you know,
Chit with g coming off,
you know that drawl now there's a lot more hype with everyone's getting tuned
in.
The ratings are going to be better.
And my boxing judges,
you know,
they're crooked.
MMA is nowhere near as bad,
but bots like did you,
did you see the wilder ots fight?
No.
I thought for sure wilder was losing on the cards and like he's going to have to
get a finish,
but on actual scorecards they had wild or winning,
which off see they want wilder to win.
Which was I thought was I was like I did and I'm a wilder Dick Rider.
I'm like,
he's not laying at fight.
MMA might be worse.
And they're the same exact judges saying it's a bad idea is a lot of the same
judges that judge that also are judge box and also judge MMA and they don't even
know what MMA is.
You UNDC trying to walk that tight rope of not clown and what's her name?
Abalene state bird.
She's a very nice lady.
But as you said,
I'm so,
it was my mom.
I don't want her to fucking piss exactly what Matt judging.
That's exactly what I said.
And so fun UTC,
just trying to balance that.
She has no business being in the,
in the note was very nice lady.
But yeah,
she's made some bad decisions.
And she also was a part all in though.
She was also a part of the Canelo Alvarez triple g decision.
That's the problem.
Yeah,
she's balling.
Yeah.
And she was on the wrong side of a couple of decisions that night.
There was some,
there was some bad ones.
Super so site to some that we were like,
what,
how did he win every round wives?
Oh you didn't make any sense like some that some that literally didn't make any
sense each time on the UFC this past weekend there was a lot of bad decision.
Bad ones.
Yeah.
But there was like a couple of split decisions that I was like,
what in the actual fuck is this?
And the weight screws over the fine.
They've knowing the repercussions is such a shitty deal.
Yup.
Yeah.
They lose half their money,
their money,
my money.
Cause you don't know what's going on.
And literally the,
there's no recourse.
And if it's a bad decision and there's three people and one person just has
literally no idea what they're doing and they give it to the wrong person,
it's awful man.
It's fucking terrible and it's unnecessary.
Here's the thing,
it's unnecessary.
There's way better methods.
And one of the most better methods is one of the better methods is hire someone
who was an actual martial arts expert.
Like I'm Matt Hume or something like that.
Someone to score like,
oh you can,
I'm sure there's a lot of those guys that would do it.
A lot of trainers out there that would do it.
I think.
I agree.
You need to have someone who specializes in mixed martial arts.
She's been around the game.
I don't,
they don't need to be Kate side cause case.
I can't see everything.
And you're also swayed by the crowd.
They shouldn't be in an undisclosed location and they're watching what we see in
judging the fight from the MMA fighters perspective.
I think that's a good point.
And I also think they should be able to see all the replays.
Yes,
they should see all the fight stat.
So they get everything,
get everything,
copies,
strikes and then decide.
But what you're doing now is so old school,
the only thing that I would disagree with,
I don't think they should hear the commentary because I think the commentary can
sway.
I'm saying no,
come to calm the crowd noise.
You have three expert MMA and watching going this who was winning cause you're
gonna.
They know what the ground game,
you know for that.
For Tony Ferguson,
Khabib let's say could be takes Tony Down and they think,
oh he has a huge advantage and then Tony just whooping his ass,
throws back,
elbows submission game stand back up can take down.
But on the ground it can be constantly under threat.
How are you going to judge that?
How are yeah,
you gotta know what you're looking at.
I also think three is too small.
I think it should be 10 people,
10 people.
A lot of people can't qualify.
I'm calling.
It's a real shit show.
Alan,
do it all.
Do,
do it all with the Internet.
You didn't even have to be in the building.
Why not be there 10 though?
10 people.
It's harder for three more,
but if there's two that are smart and one that's bad,
you've got to shitty split decision and everybody feels weird about it.
Like what would have happened if there was three more?
So can we say five 10 10 10 you're going to get the right decision almost every
time cause to a few people are going to,
but most people are going to see it.
That one majority is going to see it this way and agree.
And if it's five to five,
you've got to fuck a draw in your hands.
And that's rare.
I'm not mad at that.
And I think sometimes a fight should be a fucking draw and watch it go,
man,
that's too close to call.
Don't fuck over Sonia.
And half their pay.
If there's a drawl,
they both get their wisdom.
That's how we should do.
Exactly.
One guy moves on and the other guy doesn't just arbitrarily so weird.
It doesn't make any sense.
Or you get a draw and they have to in the contract they rematch on whatever card
the Rady go again.
Okay.